[MUSIC PLAYING]
[WHOOSH]
JEREMY WALKER: Welcome to
"YouTube Developers Live." We
have a great show
today revolving
around a new Data API.
We have the PM and
the lead eng--
engineer-- here to talk
a little bit about it.
And we have a lot of
questions for them.
But before we get started, let
me introduce everyone,
including our guests.
I'm Jeremy Walker.
I'm part of the Developer
Relations
Team here for YouTube.
And we have Greg Schechner.
How are you doing, Greg?
GREG SCHECHTER: I'm
doing well.
Don't throw any N's
in my name.
It's Schechter.
But that's all right.
JEREMY WALKER: Schechter.
OK, sorry about that.
Did you stay up late for the
election or anything?
GREG SCHECHTER: Well, I mean in
California it kind of ended
pretty early, so I don't have to
stay up that late to watch.
But, you know.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Great.
Well, we have Jeff Posnick
from New York.
And I suspect you probably
had to wait in line
for a while to vote.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah, I tried to
time things pretty well.
So I voted right after work.
Actually, the line was not
too bad at that point.
But did definitely stay up a
little bit past my bedtime to
watch the results.
JEREMY WALKER: And then
from Europe, we
have our special guests.
We have Raul Furnica.
He's a lead engineer for
the YouTube APIs.
You there, Raul?
RAUL FURNICA: Hi.
Yeah, I'm Raul Furnica.
I'm the tech lead of the
YouTube API Team.
JEREMY WALKER: And then we have
Vlad Vuskovic, who is the
product manager.
VLAD VUSKOVIC: Yeah, that's me.
Hi.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Well, we're really excited to
have you guys on today.
We have a bunch of questions.
Just to talk a little bit
about the API for you.
For any of you out there that
don't know, we did release a
new Data API version 3 for
YouTube, and we just wanted to
talk a little bit about that.
So I guess our first question
revolves around, why did we
rewrite the YouTube Data API?
VLAD VUSKOVIC: So I'll take
this one to start.
So the old API got a bit old.
So after five years for v1 and
four years for v2, we kind of
thought that it's time to change
it a bit and make it
more modern.
Introduce some new elements.
So the old API was still based
on the [INAUDIBLE] responses.
We thought that we needed some
efforts in compatible changes.
We also then used the occasion
to launch a bunch of really
new, cool features in
API like the topics
API universal search.
And a bunch of technical
improvements.
And perhaps you can
go into them.
RAUL FURNICA: So there is a
lot I had to do with the
loading format.
We had some XML that we didn't
like anymore in the old
version, version 2
and version 1.
And now we basically use
JSON by default for
the response format.
We also are adding new features
on the [INAUDIBLE]
like partial resources, which
we're probably going to talk
about it during the
meeting today.
We're adding in new services
that we never had, that
already Vlady discussed.
So it's all about new stuff that
we couldn't do before and
we feel like we [INAUDIBLE]
do now.
VLAD VUSKOVIC: It's something
you learn along the way, and
we thought now it's
time to use that.
JEREMY WALKER: Oh, great.
Would you guys mind giving a
little bit more information on
the infrastructure?
RAUL FURNICA: In particular, in
infrastructural API design,
you can see a couple of changes
in the responses and
the request format.
I would like to highlight
a couple of things.
One of them is the partial
responses.
So from now on you basically can
say whatever you need to
to request from the resources
you retrieve from the API in a
parameter called part.
I don't know if actually
people checked the
documentation already
or not, but a video
can mean many things.
A video can be a lot
of information
about recording location.
Or it can be about [INAUDIBLE]
description.
Or it can be about content
of the video.
Or it can be about information
about the video being in 3D or
not and so on.
So a video means many things
to many people.
And we added a system so now
people just say what does
video mean for them?
And retrieve the video parts
that are interesting.
So parts are logical groups
of fields that you can
[INAUDIBLE]
request to retrieve.
So part=snippet would retrieve
only the snippet of a video,
and not the rest of the
information, which makes it
good for the bandwidth and good
for the API itself in
terms of design and [INAUDIBLE]
and cleanness.
Another thing that
I would like to
mention is the snippet.
We have this approach right now
in YouTube that we didn't
have in version 2,
and I wish we had
there from the beginning.
We think that every YouTube
resource should have a
thumbnail, to put it simply.
So we have five specially named
snippets, which contains
the types and the description
and thumbnails.
And that part is available for
any resource served by the
YouTube API.
So anything you would see in the
YouTube API, you should be
able to easily build a graphical
interface with a
image, with a thumbnail.
And just some views are
what this is about.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah,
I noticed that.
That really helped a lot,
especially when you're doing
certain searches.
It's really easy to get
it and pull it up.
I noticed it has this
experimental label.
Can you guys talk a little
bit about what
that actually means?
VLAD VUSKOVIC: "Experimental"
basically means that we are
not done yet.
It means that we are
still listening to
feedback from the community.
If that feedback tells us that
we need to change stuff, then
we will consider
changing stuff.
It just means that we are going
to keep adding features
and developing the
API further.
Once we think that we
are done, then we
will remove the label.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Great.
RAUL FURNICA: Before like--
JEREMY WALKER: Let's say you are
on v2, which quite a few
people are.
When should they start thinking
about porting over?
Should they port now?
What would you say are the
missing features from v3, or
that are in v2 that are maybe
not in v3 yet, but are coming?
RAUL FURNICA: So that's what
I was going to say before.
Basically, we have
a huge legacy
to live up to, basically.
In version 2, we have
a lot of features.
And while most of it is going to
make it back into v3, into
our streamlined version,
and like a very
nice reworked APIs.
Not all of it is going
to come back.
There are certain features where
YouTube is not prepared
to be [INAUDIBLE]
into right now.
Like inbox, for instance, and
messaging in between users is
not something that we're going
to prioritize very high on the
features we're going
to have in v3.
VLAD VUSKOVIC: Eventually
they make it.
It's just that it's, as
you say, they are low
priority right now.
Because someone's using them.
RAUL FURNICA: Yeah.
So right now, we launched v3
with the core features, so
that includes videos, playlists
and channels.
And we keep adding to those.
All the stuff we don't have
yet, there is particular
extensions we added recently--
by recently, I mean the
last couple of years--
to v2 about live that we don't
have yet, and we will
work for adding it.
We have more about content
discovery, so we have more
about people's charts
and [INAUDIBLE]
content.
So we haven't had time
yet to add it in v3.
And [INAUDIBLE]
I miss anything?
I think that's all
[INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE]
keep you out.
JEFF POSNICK: One thing I wanted
to add that isn't yet
in version 3 is support
for push updates
or for smart polling.
There are some version 2
developers who might be using
PubSubHubbub or SUP for doing
kind of like smart polling or
push updates.
I'm saying this publicly to
encourage to the engineering
team to prioritize that for
v3 because I know that's
something I'm really looking
forward to seeing added.
RAUL FURNICA: [INAUDIBLE].
We're looking at it.
JEFF POSNICK: We have
you on video.
Now you're committed.
RAUL FURNICA: Yeah.
JEREMY WALKER: And don't forget
to keep an eye on our
blog and our Google+ page as we
announce those features as
they come out.
You guys talked a little bit
about some of the features
you're excited about.
I think you mentioned topics
and partial responses.
Do you guys want to give us
a little bit more, share a
little bit more of
what's going on?
I hear that universal searches
is pretty cool, too.
VLAD VUSKOVIC: Yeah.
So topics is something we are
really excited about.
It's a completely new API.
Basically, we are making the
link between entities and
videos for the first time so
that people can do semantic
searches in videos and get
videos that are related, let's
say, to Sacramento the city
rather than Sacramento the
basketball team.
So this is something that we
really hope will help a lot of
apps discover new content
in a new way.
The other thing that you just
mentioned is universal search.
So basically it is also a
feature that we are proud of.
It is basically we are
rethinking the search from
ground up here.
We're allowing you to search
among all YouTube entities.
So perhaps there is a channel
which is more related to a
search query than some videos.
So universal search means that
you will serve your results
based on the search scores among
all YouTube entities.
You can always restrict them
to certain-- like only to
videos, or only to playlists,
or only to channels.
But you can also just
search all together.
That allows us to serve you
better results, and also
allows you to write
applications
that use this feature.
So other things that Raul
already went into.
We are really proud of some of
the technical improvements.
You already went into it.
You can say more if you want.
RAUL FURNICA: Yeah, I want
to sneak in something.
I know there has been a talk
feature request from external
[? organizer, ?]
or a [INAUDIBLE]
list.
We are going to have a way to
retrieve your subscribers.
It's just like a simple
thing, but it's there.
Then we're going to have a
uniform way to work with a
list of videos which is going
to be the playlist.
So you can retrieve user
uploads through a
playlist right now.
Anybody builds an application
that is a playlist player,
it's going to be able
to handle any
list of videos, basically.
One more thing that we haven't
yet released, but we're
looking into adding it really
soon, is something that I need
to add because super geeky,
and it's like
an engineering thing.
We want to support protocol
buffers externally.
That's something I'm looking
forward to see through and see
some of our users use.
And just [INAUDIBLE].
It's going to be basically
binary serialized response
format, which is much more
effective and efficient than
any text format, even
binary JSON.
JEREMY WALKER: That's
very cool,
GREG SCHECHTER: I was actually
wondering, if I have an app
that's using the v2 API, do I
have to worry about things
getting deprecated in the future
if I don't have time to
commit to the v3 yet?
VLAD VUSKOVIC: So
it is like this.
Certainly we're not going to
announce the deprecation of v2
before removing the experimental
label.
Even after that, we're going to
give a long notice so that
people have a lot of time.
If you have a video app, you
shouldn't be worrying about
what you need until 2015.
Only after that, we might
see deprecating.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
I have another question.
In version 2, part of the API
was the insight API, which let
you pull analytics
information.
And now with the new version
of the Data API, which is
version 3, we now have also
a separate Analytics API.
Can you talk a little bit about
the relationship now
that those have split?
RAUL FURNICA: You can stay
with two different APIs.
You actually see them, the
developer console is two
different APIs.
You can register for each
of them for your app.
They're actually built on the
same [INAUDIBLE] stack right
now, so they integrate
very nicely.
So you can use the same
client library to
query either of them.
So you can have a cross query
between the two APIs with the
same client library without
much [INAUDIBLE].
The authentication would
be the same.
You would use the same user for
the Analytics API as you
use for the Data API.
So there isn't a lot of
integration just because
they're [INAUDIBLE]
on the same API interface.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Yeah, I had written a sample
in both, and once you learn
one, the authentication
is the same.
And also the new Analytics API,
you can get information
back in JSON or CSV
format directly.
We're going to talk more about
that next week at our GGL, so
make sure you tune in
for that as well.
JEFF POSNICK: Cool.
One topic that I wanted to bring
up, and to jump in here.
Anybody who's watched some of
the older episodes will know
that I'm really into YouTube
API quota issues.
I think I spent about 30 minutes
on one of our previous
week's shows talking about
how quota applies to
version 2 of the API.
But version 3 of the API
is a complete rewrite.
There's a different back end,
and I wanted to just see what
kind of quota considerations
people should take into
account when they're developing
against v3.
RAUL FURNICA: Yeah.
Quota has been reworked,
as well.
Very, very well, or partly built
into the part partial
requests and partial
resources.
So the more you request about a
resource, the more parts you
include in your request, the
more quota you're going to pay
for that request.
That's something that we want
to basically incentivize
[? some ?] developers to be
careful about the size of the
response and only request
data they need.
So [INAUDIBLE]
and actually listing out all the
parts every resource has.
So you can check out that a
video has resources like I did
sneak [INAUDIBLE]
details in song.
The general idea is that the
more you include, the more
quota costs you incur.
You can say that normally you
can retrieve a video with five
resources, you would pay a
quota cost of 10 out of
[? uniques ?]
you see in the API console.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah, I think
we're a lot more transparent
in general in version 3 about
quota, which is something a
lot of people have asked
about in the previous
versions of the API.
So we do actually include some
real numbers, and help people
make some calculations about how
expensive their calls are
and how many quota units they
have per day at fault, and
things like that.
RAUL FURNICA: Right.
We're also making sure in the
documentation we're putting
information about how expensive
each part is, and
which are the parts that you
can really query a lot,
because they release
[INAUDIBLE].
Retrieve and we charge
a lot [INAUDIBLE]
more expensive to retrieve.
JEFF POSNICK: Cool.
OK.
Greg and Jeremy, if you don't
mind right now, I was going to
kind of take over the
presentation a bit, and switch
into doing a live demo of
showing off some concepts that
are important to version
3 of the API.
This is something that's going
to be driven entirely from
within the documentation,
which is something I
particularly like about
version 3 of the API.
Let me just make sure I'm
choosing the right window.
OK.
So hopefully folks can see
my screen at this point.
What I have open right
here is the live
documentation for version 3.
It's at
developers.google.com/youtube.
And you can get from there
to version 3 docs.
In addition to documenting all
the different parameters that
specific requests take, if you'd
look down here at the
bottom of the page-- let me just
reload that to make sure
it's fresh--
you see this Try It section.
This is actually a live web
based request that you can
make that will go directly
against the Production API.
You'll see what your request
looks like, and you'll see
what the response looks
like as JSON.
Even if you plan on using
the client library--
maybe you're a Python
programmer or a Java
programmer--
even though your actual code
won't necessarily look like
this, this is a great way to try
out requests, try to see
what the different parts
include, try different
parameters, and get familiar
with the API before you
actively have to sit down
and type out code.
I think there's a common, not
very productive developer
pattern where you kind of type
in some code, you run the
request, you maybe sniff the
output, or you take a look at
the logging details of the
output, and then you re-run
the request.
And that takes time.
So this is really cool.
JEREMY WALKER: Hey, Jeff.
Jeff, can you bump up your
font a little bit?
It's hard to see on the video.
So if you could bump that
up, that'd be great.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
I'm bumping up the size
of my screen--
JEREMY WALKER: Thank you, sir.
JEFF POSNICK: --a little bit.
Hopefully, folks can see
that pretty well.
I'm going to show--
first of all, you could use
OAuth 2 from directly within
this tool, which is great.
So you don't have to enter your
user name or password
name anywhere.
You have the standard
benefits of OAuth 2.
What I'm going to do is make
a Channels List call.
I'm going to specify the
part, contentDetails.
Over here, I'm going to specify
the parameter mine as
"true."
What this is going to do is it's
going to return My Own
Channel, the channel of the
authenticated user.
It's very similar to what the
defaults user was in version 2
of the API.
It's going to give me some
details about that channel.
I click Execute down here.
See that happen, and you
see the response.
So you see both what the actual
URL is over here, and
you see the response JSON in a
nice, pretty printed format.
I'm going to walk you through
something that's really common
to do in version 3.
You kind of take playlist ideas
that you might get from
either the Channels List over
here, or you might get a
playlist ID from doing a
universal search, or some
other method.
Then you take that playlist ID,
and you plug it into the
playlistitems.list method in
order to get the contents of
playlist ID.
This is actually really great
because everything is a
playlist, as Raul mentioned.
And the user uploads feed
is also just a playlist.
So I'm going to get my specific
playlist ID from my
uploads feed directly
from this response.
I'm going to copy
it over here.
And then I'm going to go back
up to PlaylistItems, list.
And I get to use the live
demo again over here.
Scroll down to the bottom.
In this case, I'm going
to ask for the
snippet for each video.
I'm going to put in--
I'm actually just going to put
in two results per page over
here, and I'm going to put in
as a playlist ID that user
identifier that I got from
my previous call.
So I'm clicking Execute
over here.
I can see the response.
I see some kind of metadata
about the response feed.
There's four results.
They're showing me two results
in this response.
And you see the actual, relevant
details about the
items that are in my
uploads playlist.
So in this case, you'll
see some thumbnails.
You'll see the title.
You'll see the date that
it was published, and a
description for those things.
So again, regardless of whether
you're dealing with a
user uploads list of videos
or our traditional YouTube
playlist of videos, or the feed
of all the videos that
somebody has liked, all these
things are treated exactly the
same in version 3.
So that really simplifies
the type of code
that you have to write.
You don't have to write special
case code, depending
upon which type of list
you're going against.
So that's cool.
I wanted to now also just
show you how paging
works in version 3.
So similar to version 1 and 2
of the API, we can't return
every single video that might
match a certain query within
the same response.
You might have an extremely
large list of uploads, for
instance, or a playlist might
have up to 200 items.
It's just really not very
efficient to return all of
that in the exact
same response.
So the way that was done in
version 2 of the API and
version 1 of the API was by
using start index parameter.
You could specify kind of the
position within the list that
you wanted to start up
when you retrieved
the specific request.
That's done away with in version
3 of the API, and
instead we make use of unique
tokens, basically, that allow
you to move backwards and
forwards one page of requests.
So you can't just jump to an
arbitrary position within a
list of videos anymore, but you
can either go to the next
page or the previous page.
In order to make use of that,
I'm going to take this next
page token value.
I'm going to scroll all
the way up here.
And I'm going to put it in the
pageToken variable over here.
Click Execute.
You can see that the request
URL changed a
bit to include pageToken.
And if you look at the response,
it will be the next
two videos in the feed.
So that's a really important
concept to be aware of.
Paging is one of the things
that differs.
JEREMY WALKER: I was going to
say, one thing that I found
really, really useful, too, is
the fields, the field section.
What I often found is I'd run
a query with this, and then
I'd figure out, OK, now
I can pare it down to
just the data I need.
Then you can figure that out
using that little link there.
You can check off exactly
what you need.
Then you can copy and paste that
with the library so that
you get an exact response.
JEFF POSNICK: Little daunting
trying to come with the
correct syntax, but this does
a great job of automatically
generating for you.
If you do it from within the
docs, you use the fields
editor over there.
You can just get the
snippets back.
In this case, you will get rid
of a few of the extra things.
I also wanted to cover something
a little different.
This was something that Raul
was talking about before,
something he really liked,
which was the support for
different parts when
making requests.
I'm going to do that
by demonstrating
a Videos list request.
The Videos list is how you get
this metadata for one or more
different videos.
You could enter a whole
comma-separated list of video
IDs if you want.
In this case, I'm just going to
use that one video ID from
my previous example.
But I'm going to take a look
over here and see the part
parameter for Videos list
supports all these different
[INAUDIBLE].
So maybe what I'm most
interested in is the player
information about a
specific video.
I don't care about the
statistics in my API call.
I don't really care about what
the topics that are associated
with the video is.
All I really care about is
the player information.
That's something that I can
explicitly request, and I
won't get any extra data
that I don't care
about in the response.
That means it'll be cheaper
from a quota perspective.
And it also means that there's
fewer bytes being transferred
over the network, so the request
should come back a
little bit faster.
I do that over here.
I put in part=player.
You see I get--
every request is going
to contain the ID.
You don't explicitly have
to ask for that
to get the ID back.
I do see an ID.
I see what the kind
of video it is.
But the only extra thing
I see here is player.
And I get embed HTML.
If I wanted to embed the
standard YouTube player on a
web page, I could use this
iframe snippet to do it.
Just to show you how that
differs, if I switch this now
to contentDetails and click
Execute, I get, in this
particular case, the content
details for a video will give
you the duration.
This is a five second
long video.
It's not either/or.
If I know that I need both
parts, I could just put them
in a comma-separated list, and
I will get both of them back.
So you really have fine grain
control over the amount of
data that you get back.
I also know that Raul and the
engineering team is kind of
happy that this makes it easy to
add new data to the API in
a very backwards
compatible way.
If we start exposing a whole new
type of metadata about a
given video, we could
just create a new
part for doing that.
Nothing in the existing parts
will have to change.
You could start requesting
that new part if you were
really interested.
Finally, I wanted
to demonstrate
probably topic search.
Although, we did this before in
one of our previous Google
Development Live events.
I wasn't able to join,
unfortunately.
You know what?
I'm going to consider doing
the topic search.
I'm just going to show universal
search, I think.
But definitely check out the
previous week's episode that
we dedicated to the Topics API
because that's a really very
interesting, well, topic.
Pardon the pun.
And I recommend folks look into
that a little bit more.
I'm just going to show off
quickly how you can do a
universal search.
We're going to do it by
scrolling down to
the bottom over here.
We'll get to the sample
code in a bit.
If you try it, we're going
to say we want snippet.
We want the query term of,
let's say, New York.
That could be put in
topic over here.
Type is where we get to specify
either video, channel,
or playlist.
In this case, I want to return
pretty much anything.
We'll let the API back
end determine
how to rank the results.
It might be a channel.
It might be a playlist.
It might be a video.
I don't know what it's going
to be in advance.
The API will put the most
relevant things first.
[INAUDIBLE]
the first thing that it ends
up returning is actually a
YouTube channel for the "New
York Times." The second thing
that it will end up returning is
a YouTube video for Jay-Z's
"New York State of Mind."
These are all
mixed in to the results.
If you've ever done a search
on youtube.com, you'll know
that you get something
very similar.
If you search for "New York" on
YouTube, you'll get back a
mix of playlists and channels
and videos.
So now you could have that same
experience from within
your own application.
So that's pretty cool.
I think those are the main
things I wanted to
show for right now.
But the important thing is that
anybody could go on to
our documentation, read the
docs, get familiar with the
API, and then just scroll down a
little bit to the bottom and
instantly make their own calls
and get familiar with the
actual responses.
So that's a real big
improvement for
developers, I think.
GREG SCHECHTER: Thank you
for that demo job.
That was great.
I was actually wondering if I'm
like a developer, and I'm
trying to use this stuff, are
there places for me to get
help or maybe provide feedback,
because it still is
experimental?
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah,
absolutely.
Our standard place to go for
questions related to any of
the YouTube APIs, and that
certainly includes version 3
of the API, is Stack
Overflow now.
We ask that anybody who posts
questions on Stack Overflow
use the tag youtube-api,
and that'll help
us find their questions.
We are also looking for
feedback, and bug reports, and
feature requests, and things
that are not necessarily
appropriate for Stack
Overflow.
If you just have a general
feature request or if you
found a bug, we are using the
same issue tracker that we've
been using for a while now.
There's links to that directly
from our documentation for
both finding a feature request
or reporting a bug.
It would help us a little bit
if you use, I guess, the
characters "v3" somewhere in
both your Stack Overflow or
your issue tracker requests,
just so we can help those
things bobble up to the
top a little bit.
But we'll take a look
at everything.
We'll evaluate them
as best we can.
GREG SCHECHTER: Cool.
I think we wrote a blog post on
it, too, if somebody wanted
more details on where the
links are and stuff.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah,
absolutely.
That's on apiblog.youtube.com.
You can find that.
GREG SCHECHTER: Awesome.
Are there examples available?
I mean other than
the Explorer?
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah,
definitely.
We are doing our best to keep
up with the wide array of
languages that all
the developers
out there are using.
We're kind of focusing on a few
specific languages that
we're writing samples
for to begin with.
So we have a decent number of
Python's samples right now.
We have a good number of
JavaScript samples.
Thank you, Greg.
I know that you've been the
one primarily to do those.
We're working on some Ruby
samples, some Java samples.
I think Germany's going to
be adding pretty soon.
One of the nice things about the
sample code is that it's
also going to be inline
in the documentation.
So as you're viewing the
description of a specific
method, and you're viewing the
parameters, and things like
that, certain pages do have
a section of the docs.
Briefly, I scrolled past
it when I was doing
a search list method.
I think that might have actually
been a PHP example
that we had in there for
doing a video search.
So you can kind of see
everything within context.
You know, this is the
primary definition.
This is some sample
code for a variety
of different languages.
And down here is the live
Explorer where you can play
around with the API
yourselves.
In addition to those samples,
we're also working on a few
kind of like standalone
applications to show people
more than just a snippet
of code.
This is a real world
application.
It was built using v3, or in
some cases, something that was
written initially against
version 1 or version 2 of the
API, ported to v3, and show
you what the process of
porting it to v3 entailed.
One example right now, the
standalone application is a
YouTube Topic Explorer, which
we covered in the previous
week when we talked about
YouTube Topics.
You can go out and watch
our old episode
for a link to that.
I'm personally working on
porting both Party Playlist
Picker and YouTube Direct
Lite, which are two open
source projects I wrote that are
using both version 1 and
version 2 of the API.
I'm working on porting that to
version 3 to try to, I guess,
eat our own dog food, to some
extent, and also document what
the process is for folks who
are making that migration.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Thanks for that Jeff.
Vlad and Raul, we have a
couple of questions we
probably want to get to before
we let you guys go, because I
know it's late over
there in Europe.
Let's go through a
couple questions.
GREG SCHECHTER: Excellent.
One of the questions I see
here is there is a switch
between going from the XML
to JSON with the v3 APIs.
One guy is wondering about the
libraries that are available
to use that.
Actually, we've got
some great tools.
We have the Google Client
Libraries, which will do a lot
of the API handling.
They'll even deal with things
like storing some of the
authentication keys.
So you can find more information
about that on
developers.google.com.
All of the examples that we're
building are using these
client libraries.
So those should be able to help
you just sort of convert
to using v3 and using JSON
for these responses.
The other thing is, one guy
asked about the different
philosophy with the design and
how v2 is doing this big data
dump and v3 is just doing
like the little pieces.
They wanted to know why.
We covered that a little
bit earlier, but I'm
just going to reiterate.
Basically, you're going
to get less data.
Just the data you want, which
means that the request is
going to be faster, so it's
going to be a lot more
performance and not use
as much bandwidth.
So that's good for you.
If you're building your app,
it's going to be faster.
It's good for us because it's
just easier for us to handle
greater loads when we're not
sending as much bytes.
The other question.
Best way to submit feedback.
We already talked about that.
There's a blog post on it
at apiblog.youtube.com.
The last question--
one of the other questions was
somebody was wondering if the
video to topics relationship
is experimental.
Not just the API, but they
wanted to know if the
relationship.
Or is that something that's
sort of solidified?
Are these things changing?
I don't know if anyone
can talk about that.
VLAD VUSKOVIC: We're trying to
improve our algorithms to
determine that as we go.
So we expect it to get
better and better.
I think it's already like
really, really good.
RAUL FURNICA: Just
to add to that.
The feature itself, it's nice
for us that there is going to
be topics for videos.
That's my intent with it.
The topics particularly that we
associate with a particular
video might change in time as
our algorithms get better.
But the feature is
there to stay.
VLAD VUSKOVIC: Actually,
we want to improve.
So to improve the feature,
currently we are serving the
topics for the video.
But we will add it for channels
as well, and for
playlists in future.
So it's there to stay, yeah.
GREG SCHECHTER: That's great.
Thanks, guys.
Then the last question, which
we see all the time is, "is
YouTube and Google Developer
Relations hiring?" Jeremy,
what's the answer to that one?
JEREMY WALKER: Yes, we
are always hiring.
So definitely check that out.
If you go to
developers.google.com/jobs,
you should be able to
see some listings.
But we are definitely hiring,
so if you are interested,
check that out.
I think that covers
all the questions.
GREG SCHECHTER: Yeah,
that's all the
questions we had today.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
So again, check out
the new versions.
Vlad and Raul, thank you so much
for coming and answering
some of our questions.
And go out there and try it, and
give us feedback as soon
as you can.
Thanks.
VLAD VUSKOVIC: Can I just
get last feedback, guys?
We are really committed
to this API.
We are going to work hard to
make it better and better.
One of the good things about the
new API infrastructure is
that it will allow us to deploy
new features much
faster than in the past.
So expect a lot of new features
coming out in
[INAUDIBLE].
RAUL FURNICA: Yeah, I've been on
the API team for six years,
and this is the best API yet.
GREG SCHECHTER: That's
great to hear.
Yeah.
RAUL FURNICA: [INAUDIBLE],
actually.
JEREMY WALKER: Cool.
Well, thanks, guys.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
RAUL FURNICA: Thank you.
GREG SCHECHTER: Bye,
everybody.
[WHOOSH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]